[موسيقى]
اذا ما فكرنا بالحرب البارده بالوقت
المتحده واتحاد السوفيتي فكانت
نزاعا ايدولوجيا عالميا بين الشيوعيا وبين
الاساليب الحره للسياساتي والاقتصاديه
كانت امبراطوريه متعدده الاوطان وما عادت
موجوده الان الحرب البارده اعتبرت على
انها انتهت رسميا عندما انهار الاتحاد
السوفيتي او اتقسم الى روسيا وجمهوريه
الاخرى هذا لن يحصل مع روسيا اليوم
وكذلك
ليست منافسه دوليه ايديولوجيه الكل يستطيع
ان يقول ابن الشيوعيه فشلت لانها ما عادت
الدوله الشيوعيه بل هي دوله روسيا ضعفت
باشكال كثيره ولكن مع ذلك كما شخص الرئيس
بوتين فهي الدوله ذات طموحات انترياليه
[موسيقى]
نحن الامريكيون يجب ان ننظر داخل حدودنا
فيما يخص الديمقراطيه معنا ان نتذكر
الاحداث التي حصلت قبل اقل من عامين عندما
كان هنالك رئيس خسر الانتخابات
واحاول ان يقوم بعمليه انقلاب المحافظه
على السلطه واستمر منذ ذلك الوقت باكاذبها
حول نتائج تلك الانتخابات
قبل ان تحاول اي حكومه امريكيه عن تلقي
المحاضرات على الديمقراطيه لاي حكم اخرى
يجب ان ننظر الى ما يحصل هنا داخل بلادنا
اما فيما يخص
مشكله الكبيره بهذا الخصوص ما تحدث عنه
يخص حول كيف بعض السياسات التي نسمعهم
السياسيين في واشنطن مواقفنا حول هذه
المساله وكذلك حول العديد من المسائل اقصد
مسائل السياسه الخارجيه هي تعكس
التنافس بين الحزبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي اكثر مما هي حول
التحليلات الدقيقه لما يصب في مصلحه
امريكا او السلام العالمي
[موسيقى]